we begin here though with some breaking  news this morning one person was hit and  killed early this morning not too far  from nellis air force base this happened  just after two o'clock this morning at  las vegas boulevard and lamb metro  police say the driver involved initially  did not stop after hitting the  pedestrian  the victim was killed at the scene the  driver was found a short time later at  an apartment complex nearby that person  is now in custody we'll continue to  follow the story all throughout the  morning we're going to talk again about  more of these deadly crashes on our  roads some of the statistics it's pretty  shocking